empty tracks carriages at a standstill
the signs of yet another train strike
now it's the turn of the driver no pay
rise in three years they say it's a time
to take a stand
on the picket line at piccadilly in
manchester some of the 500 drivers
striking in the region
dave's been working in the rail industry
for 32 years and says this is the most
challenging time he's faced i'm angry
that we've had to get to this position
there's no there's no need for it
because there could have been
discussions taking place and we could
matters could have been resolved without
need for strike action the concern is as
inflation rises dave's level of pay
remains the same but train drivers
across the uk earn 54 000 pounds on
average per year
some might say yes you're well paid we
have got a good standard of living but
it's it's because over many many years
we've negotiated on our terms and
conditions our flexibility we need to
get a pay rise to protect ourselves from
the cost of living
thousands of drivers across nine
companies agreed two weeks ago they'd
strike for 24 hours after a deadlock
dispute over pay and conditions
we told both the government and the
companies back in february this year
that all bets were off because of the
change the cost of living crisis
everyone's ignoring us
some people in the department of
transport
think that they can modernize the
railway which basically in their terms
get all the productivity they want for
nothing
but with strikes comes disruption from
football to qriket matches summer
getaways to the everyday commute
tens of thousands of people impacted
like casey who today should be at his
friend's wedding we did not realize the
full extent of of the strike and the
fact that our you know the main station
in our city would be completely shut
down um today uh and of course all the
the other methods of public transport
for getting there are either fully fully
booked or you know untenable price wise
for getting to this particular area so
it's it's very frustrating to to you
know have to to miss such a pivotal
moment in some of our friends lives
and the frustration amongst those
flooding into manchester was clear too
i think it's just being a bit greedy
especially everybody else having to cope
with the money and
everything going up the strikes didn't
have to happen if they paid them the
money that they're asking for
and the government corporations don't
want to pay them how does it make you
feel like they are out here today that
they're striking that they're causing
disruption because they can't can't be
bothered to do anything else that's what
they brainwashed even at that age
there's a bit unfair on everyone isn't
it really i don't think anyone wins
[Music]
the transport secretary says the unions
are hell bent on causing as much misery
as possible and believes pay rises can
only be funded by reform and so with no
signals of positive negotiations a
chance for this situation to change
seems far off interim rasheed sky news
manchester